This story, sadly, is about a type of insanity
that I believe is uniquely American that we
are currently facing.
Dr. Anthony Foushee now needs armed guards
because of serious, credible threats coming
his way from Trump ists and other conspiratorial
sycophants.
This story is as shocking as it is sad.
Dr. Anthony Foushee is the government's top
infectious disease doctor.
He's one of the top people in Trump's team
fighting the Corona virus pandemic.
He is not a political strategist.
He is not a brownnoser who needs to be concerned
primarily with politics, although to some
degree he does need to make sure that he doesn't
anger Donald Trump too much.
Dr. Foushee is an actual medical expert.
He is the type of person.
That should be the the the primary public
spokesperson around the virus, rather than
Donald Trump rather than politicians and consultants
and angry Trump ists have been threatening
Dr. Foushee, and he has now been assigned
an armed security detail.
Dr. Foushee was asked about security yesterday
and opted not to comment.
But we now have the reporting and we know
what's going on.
Here's how Dr. Foushee answered it yesterday.
You and Dr. Birks, have either of you received
threats of any kind or have you been given
a security detail?
Given that you've been out here every day
on cameras?
Well, I mean, anything that has to do with
security detail, I'd have to have you refer
that question to the inspector general of
HHS rather than my answer.
I'm not testing security.
Everybody loves that.
So Trump jokes there.
Everybody loves Dr. Foushee.
You know, a lot of Trump's followers don't.
A lot of Trump's followers have been threatening
Dr. Foundry's life and spreading absolutely
baseless conspiracy theories about a supposedly
nefarious role that Dr. Foushee may have.
Imagine a doctor who wants to save people,
wants to flatten the curve.
And remember, we're talking about a tiny 79
year old man who is personally at risk from
being at the White House around all sorts
of people every single day.
He's out there trying to mitigate this disease.
And Trump ists believe he's some kind of enemy
and are threatening his life.
Foushee works under the umbrella of the Department
of Health and Human Services, the secretary
of HHS.
Alex Azar.
A move to put in place a full security detail
for Anthony Foushee because of the threats
and the online attacks that have been levied
at him.
So why are Trump pissed so mad at Anthony
Foushee?
There's basically two layers to this.
First of all, sometimes Foushee, who's a doctor,
will mildly correct something that Donald
Trump says about medical things.
That's what he should be doing.
He's the medical expert, not Donald Trump.
And Trump ists are furious that Foushee has
the gall to say something different than what
Donald Trump says.
Because, after all, Trump has no idea what's
going on.
And Dr. Anthony Foushee is actually a doctor.
Wow.
Tar and feather the guy.
Right.
Then there's another layer, which is the conspiratorial
layer.
There are all sorts of conspiracies that Anthony
Foushee is a so-called deep state operative,
that he is a, you know, Clinton loving stooge,
that he's a Hillary mole inside the Trump
Health and Human Services Department, et cetera,
et cetera.
You can probably imagine that we're talking
about a guy who has devoted his life to working
for Democratic presidents and for Republican
presidents who has said his ideology is health,
not liberal, not conservative, and who's one
of the few people left that actually gives
us information when he is allowed to speak.
So, of course, the Magga clowns are threatening
the guy's life.
What kind of a movement do you have if you
are Donald Trump when they loudly come out
against a doctor trying to save people and
force an armed security detail on an infectious
disease doctor?
This bodes very poorly for the United States,
as if you didn't already know that as we have
one of the worst global responses to the pandemic,
thanks to the president not listening enough
to people like Anthony Foushee, what kind
of person are you if you threaten someone
not just for telling us the truth, but for
trying to tell those truths with the goal
of saving lives?
What does it say about us as a society that
someone like Anthony Foushee is immediately
at risk requiring an armed security detail?
It you know, depressing is a word I can find.
It doesn't really cover it.
Disturbing is probably another one.
It doesn't really cover what's what's going
on.
We have some real soul searching to do as
a country and we need to unilaterally reject
any.
Let listen.
If your participation in what is going on
here in the United States is to make baseless
conspiracy theories about Dr. Anthony Foushee
and threaten his life, you have a real problem.
And this country is not going to be able to
move forward in a serious way until those
views are completely marginalized, ostracized
and essentially reduced to almost zero.
That's where we are.
That's where
we
are right now.